everest is designed for a screen like I  max is the perfect medium point you have  the scope it the biggest mountain in the  world by the way on the bigger screen in  the world you feel the hide you feel  that the volume of the mountain and the  sounds so clear and crisp there is a  masive store hated your way you have a  huge storm and the better the sound  system is the more separation is in the  summer therefore you can hear the  details at the same time you feel the  immense power of the store  anything that makes the experience  banquet like I max is fantastic that  cinematic experience and also  experienced with all the people of that  magnitude is a part of part of the  experience we're all getting down  together let's go the oxygen stuffy  place great how much it just wraps  around you you are in the middle of it  if people have a chance you see it in  imax they should definitely go there  you